and this guy what's your story I saw you
at the theater when I walked by it like
what time today I think it was like 2
o'clock
this guy got to the theater at 2 o'clock
I thought he was a really big fan turns
out he's homeless what do you do I'm a
laser operator what a laser operator
you must get tons of you have a wife in
a couple months you got it you're
engaged Wow what if she do she know
she's not a dentist you asked for this
buddy I didn't I didn't
come here ladies let's check you out for
a second two fives make it 10 right
we're doing it we're doing it well
you have such a sweet face thank you you
like missing a chromosome or something
worse for sure for sure but but it makes
everything so much better I feel yeah I
can see that I could totally see that I
love you guys I look at you you stole a
tablecloth from Chucky Cheese it's a
recession you talking about your tits
oh my God look at that I'd like to give
you both my Space Needle but your do you
smell like Pikes Place take them down
you guys you can go back to your seats
super super cool of you ladies pick them
up here good luck with your pubic hairs
coming in
[Applause]